when we got to Liverpool Street there  was a signal so I decided to send a text  to my PA and I just press sense and of  course everything happened from that  point I felt as if I was lifted up and I  was circling around and I could see a  very bright light and I could hear from  a distance lots of screams and sort of  cyrene but continuous for what felt like  a very long time then you know I woke  off and I found myself in the train  track part of my body was underneath the  train and I could see the tunnel and I  could see the platform which means the  train had gots to and I could see the  cycle gauge and I could see the other  side and the door was part of the door  was actually stuck to my thigh and the  the door of the train had come off and  part of it was hanging and there were  people screaming and shouting on the  train and  and I could see  [Music]